hey guys today I'm gonna rank the 8 best
quirks in my ear academia vigilantes now
usually when I do these lists there's
always a theme of some kind whether it
be the best transformation quirks or the
best instant kill quirks but today is
literally just the best quirks that
exist period as many of you know
vigilantes is the spin-off manga to the
main series and it reduces us to a ton
of new and original characters and
quirks obviously however there is one
guy on this list who's appeared in both
series for reasons that you'll find out
in the video before we begin though I
want to talk about the first-ever
sponsor of this channel
I'm incredibly selective with these
sponsorship offers that I received but
this product right here guys like I'll
let them do the talkin essential oils
aromas for natural wellness and healing
but current products aren't made for
gamers now there's a better way to
holistically improve your game with
sense like strategy kill death ratio
yeah okay that may have been a fake
sponsorship but it was actually brought
to you by my real sponsor which is Rach
at a legends rate is a massive mobile
RPG game we can choose from a variety of
upgradeable champions with different
quirks I mean abilities and compete in a
campaign and a bunch of other gamers too
the daily login bonus for new players
has doubled from 90 to 180 days so that
means for the next 180 days that you log
in you'll get free shards silver or gems
every single time also you get this
legendary champion with amazing ABS and
as if that wasn't enough for the next 30
days only if you click the link in my
description you'll get over 200,000
silver coins and tree fella who's
another champion my personal favorite
thing about this is the realism of the
graphics and the way you have to be
strategy is with each passing round so
do be sure to check it out it's an
awesome game and you'll be helping out
the channel a lot if you do but with
that said let's jump into the 8th best
quirk in vigilantes so starting us off
is the lovable Oboro Shara Coomer and
his quark which is simply known as cloud
now for those of you who aren't familiar
with this character sure Akuma was a
Class A student way back in the day and
was the best friend of both Izawa and
present Mike if you look closely you can
actually see him during the outro for
season 4 his quote grants him the
ability to generate clouds at will but
it's safe to say that these aren't the
kind of flimsy clouds that you would
expect in the real world
sure Akuma is able to make them so dense
that they can tolerate heavy amounts of
weights and actually be used to store
objects inside them though the less said
about that part the better because he
has complete control over the clouds he
creates he can move them around with
telekinesis in much the same way that
horse controls his feathers or said she
controls his meat we seen him use the
clouds in a variety of ways including to
travel at far speeds to elevate himself
higher or to cover his nakedness on one
occasion he generated a cloud so dense
that it prevented a ton of heavy debris
from crushing a bunch of school children
sure Akuma is really technical with this
quirk and uses it alongside this stuff
which he carries around and he uses that
thing to hit enemies with drink class
training he demonstrated a stealthy
super move known as cloud cover so this
is when he speeds towards an enemy and
then blinds them with a small cloud then
before they regain their vision he hides
within a much larger cloud and uses this
speaker to project his voice this
distracts his opponents and then he
surprises them with a sneak attack from
a different direction
overall this quirk has a bunch of
use cases and is definitely one of the
best we've seen in vigilantes and on top
of that Sheila Kumar just an awesome guy
so yeah he is definitely worthy of
eighth place on this list
moving on to seventh we have cuicci
who's quark evolution has just been on
another level so this guy is the main
character of vigilantes and his quirk is
known as sliding Glide
when we first meet this character he
described the ability as being able to
slowly glide along the ground and it
would activate when he makes contact
with at least three limbs gradually we
see this begin to improve throughout the
series with one of the first glimpses of
his potential coming in an emergency
situation in this moment he quickly
glided up his skyscraper and then used
the momentum from that to fly into the
air following on from this we see Kui
Chi increase his speed to ridiculous
levels he was even able to overtake a
speeding bus his power grows even
further thanks to the help of Ingenium
who taught him how to brake properly
which then resulted in him building on
this power and having a great degree of
agility that we've seen demonstrated
many times throughout the series however
quite bizarrely
the biggest upgrades that we've seen for
Kui has been his ability to cling to
walls to levitate and to blast a
Kamehameha wave starting with this
walking ability this is when he
manipulates the direction of his crux
activation which enables him to fix
himself to any surface including a
speeding bullet train this feature does
not require contact with all three limbs
and in fact he can just stick to a
surface using his two feet and then use
his hands for combat this is what brings
us to his next attack which is his
Kamehameha blast or as he likes to call
it his shoot ego blam attack using the
super move he locks his feet in place
and then shoots a concentrated blast of
energy out of the palm of his hands this
move requires a charging period in which
he can build up the energy from around
his body and then condense it into a
single point before releasing it against
an opponent this is why I keep telling
you guys like just because a quirk seems
like one thing doesn't mean it can't
have applications that might seem
implausible at the beginning like
there's no way I would have thought
slide and glide would result in
concentrated energy blasts but yeah here
we are anyway his final awesome ability
is levitation
now when cuicci was a baby you should
just float in the air and in fact he
very nearly killed himself whilst doing
so so with that being the case his
mother kept smacking him until he
stopped and completely forgot that he
could ever do it in his adulthood he
would regain this ability to an extent
as we can see him using the repulsive
force to hover above the ground
and on other occasions he could use it
to spring himself up into the air or
just straight up chute blasts out of his
feet to go higher we haven't seen yet
how the story will end so maybe once
this is all over he'll be able to
properly file like he did when he was a
kid but for now this is the best he can
do next up we have shota
Aizawa who is the only character on this
list who have appeared in both
vigilantes and the main series of minor
academia the reason I included Izawa is
because unlike most people that have
crossed over
he has a ton of screen time in
vigilantes so I would be doing a
disservice not to include him on this
list here as always quark is known as
Oratia which cancels out the quirks of
anyone he's looking at this can affect
multiple targets simultaneously and he
only needs to see one part of the
targets body to cancel out their quark
individual antes we see I saw his origin
story in which he severely lacks
confidence and considers himself to be
powerless but in typical Aizawa fashion
he still gets top grades in both the
practical exams and the academic exams
what a guy Aizawa compensates for his
quirks lack of combat ability with his
insane technical skill which he used to
single-handedly defeat an incredible
villain that actually appears later on
in this list so I'm gonna save I'm gonna
save that for later
if this quirk was given to someone who
wasn't as smart or as motivated as
Aizawa is then yeah he'll probably be
pretty trashed but thanks to his 5 out
of 6 intelligence and his handy scarf
he's been able to do some amazing things
with this imp identities including
taking down this giant kaiju and saving
koishi's life in the process and also
saving captain celebrity from what would
have been most likely a fatal explosion
in Kiki's case though he did repay the
favor later by saving aizawa's life as
well okay so at fifth place we have the
quirk known as queen bee which is a
pretty strange one so this quirk allows
the user to control a swarm of mutant
bees as well as take over the body of a
human host the actual quirk user is this
parasite which is a queen bee and once
it gains control of someone's brain and
their body and quark everything is
theirs to control that said the host
body does have their personality kind of
merged with the Queen but ultimately the
original person is not in control
anymore once the Queen takes over now
the worker bees that the user controls
each of them have capsules in their bot
that allow them to contain a variety of
useful substances for example she can
create these exploding bees that
detonate whenever the user decides and
we've actually seen this used to destroy
an entire neighborhood in one of the
recent chapters
you can also fill these bees up with
poison or potentially quark enhancing
drugs which has actually been done in
the series
depending on how creative the user is
it's also pretty good for stealth
missions as you can send off one bee to
do a specific job without causing too
much of a fuss the last benefit of this
quark is that to an extent it is able to
use these bees to take the quark factor
of someone else and use it for your own
benefit on one occasion a bee collected
a blood sample and what's that blood
sample was injected Queen Bee was able
to use the electricity from that
person's quirk for our own personal
advantage so to an extent there is a
capability to copy quirks in some way
for a period of time and also obviously
they you know the host body that they're
taken over they can use that person's
quirk as well the main drawback though
is that whenever bee is injured or
destroyed the user does actually feel
the pain also because she's a parasite
once it's removed from the hosts body
she's pretty helpless and loses control
of her bees but yeah despite those
glaring weaknesses to have control of an
army of mutant bees in this way and to
have control of the people's bodies and
their quirk that's worthy of fifth place
in my book as we approach the best three
quirks in vigilantes I figured I'd give
fourth place to a bunch of different
characters who will have a relation so
these characters are known as the
next-level villains and they were people
who were injected with the quark
enhancing drug known as trigger and then
kidnapped and had their bodies tinkered
with they were altered so much that they
became these unrecognizable creatures
and their quirks range quite a bit so
one example is having super-strength
combined with eight powerful arms and
another is being able to discharge
powerful waves of electricity now the
most notable next level villain is the
bomber due to their exploding
capabilities and with one of them
possessing super regeneration on one
occasion a bunch of bombers were
destroyed and then they're discarded
body parts were able to combine together
into this massive thing which almost
acted like a womb for more bombers to
grow and just eventually burst out of
their explosive capability is ridiculous
as you seen it used to take down the
tokyo sky egg in this panel here and
also used to be captain celebrity to a
pulp
despite his barrier quo but we'll get to
that in a bit next level of villains
have been a consistent and powerful
threat throughout vigilantes but what I
love about them is that three of them
have tried to resume normal life after
their experience of being turned into
everything I mean I guess you got to get
back to work sometime right and with
that said the bronze medal goes to a
quirk that has been passed around like a
hot potato I mean at least three
character
we know if I've had this quirk being
knuckleduster all for one and number six
now I explain this in more detail in one
of my more recent videos so do check
that out it'll be in the description but
for this video I'll give it a brief
overview as well so the quirk in
question is known as overclock and it
allows the users do a lot of things
actually so firstly the user can move
their body as such a far speed that to
them it looks like no one else is moving
at all this means that the user can
casually get up and attack someone
repeatedly before casually walking away
when in reality only like one or two
seconds would have passed in addition
because this quirk mates their senses
quicker as well a person using overclock
can perceive people's body movements at
a really meticulous level and use that
information to uncover their true
unconscious feelings
however overclock can be stopped if a
user suffers a concussion or if they
focus too hard on something and deprive
the brain of the necessary oxygen in my
other video I described how number six
has used this quirk in ways that
knuckleduster never had so like I said
do check that video out if you haven't
before the link will be in the
description this quirk is incredibly
similar to the way we see Quicksilver
move in the x-men series and also to the
flash as well so my guess is that it was
at least partly inspired by this if not
100% inspired now before we get into the
monstrosity that is the number one quirk
on this list we have to talk about
captain celebrities quirk which is known
as flight captain celebrity is America's
number one hero and truly is a force to
be reckoned with
flight gives him the ability to propel
himself forward at incredible speeds
which often means that he's one of the
first heroes to arrive on the scene or
he's given the task of being the one to
chase down fast villains this flight
quirk also grants him a protective
invisible barrier that basically shields
him from physical harm and from heat or
cold now it is important to state that
Captain celebrity himself specifically
goes out of his way to say that the
barrier is not what propels him forward
alright so it's a secondary ability of
his quirk and we've seen this quite
often you know with Pixie Bob's quirk
like there are a lot of quirks that have
a secondary thing that you know might
appear like a second quirk but actually
just you know the same thing when making
contact with others he can share the
protection offered by this force field
but it weakens the amount that he
himself is protected by the strength of
this barrier was displayed when he was
repeatedly attacked by this explosive
bomber and while he was being up pretty
badly
based on the attacks that he was able to
survive like a 99% sure most heroes
would have died
after the initial onslaught so yeah it's
pretty strong also the fact that he was
simultaneously supporting 50,000 people
with his bare hands while that was
happening you got to give the guy a
break if you want to know his complete
backstory and some of the other ways
he's used this quirk then do check out
that video as well the link is in the
description but with that said the
number one quirk in Maya academia
vigilantes in my opinion is possessed by
a villain known as Garvey now Garvey is
this giant frog like creature and he
made his first appearance during a
flashback to aizawa's teenage years and
during this incident he displayed one of
the best quirks that I've ever seen so
his ability is an emitter quirk known as
stock and it allows him to absorb the
attack from other people and then store
them then he has the choice to release
the attack back at his opponents
whenever he feels like it
so whereas fat gun can soak up the
energy from someone's attack and then
release it gold we can actually take
someone's exact quirk their exact attack
and use that for example there was a
hero team back in the day called Buster
Union and present Mike was actually
interning with them as well this team
are described as the hardest-hitting
hero team around at the time they all
attacked Garvey at the exact same time
with their combined firepower and the
dude opens his mouth and literally eats
the blast like actually eats them all
these attacks were then stored within
his body and they kind of like manifest
themselves as these blobs on his back
and as we see in this panel he then
released them whenever he felt like it
when choosing which quirks to release at
what time there's clearly some
strategizing behind it as he absorbs
present Mike shouting ability and then
uses it against Prince then following up
that attack with some blast from a
different you a student which then
destroyed the building behind him the
ability to nullify people's attacks like
this and then use people's quest against
them is seriously overpowered as I was
reading this for the first time I was
seriously wondering like how the hell
are they gonna beat this guy according
to Aizawa Gavi moves really fast despite
his massive size but regardless
Aizawa was able to take him down
single-handedly because you know his
Aizawa if this clock was in the hands of
a more competent villain i'm sure that
no student would be taking him down but
that said the quote does have a weakness
in that i assume he has to absorb the
blast from his mouth so like if all my
was to punch him in the gut I assumed he
wouldn't be able to stock that up as
well but it wasn't really clear if he is
able to stock up powers that hit him
from different directions that he you
know can't eat with his mouth then that
would be
so powerful if there's one thing
vigilantes has taught me it's to not
judge a quote by its cover
so just because I haven't seen Garvey
you know absorb quotes in different ways
doesn't mean that he can't do it but if
he's not able to do that then that is a
weakness because you know people can hit
him from behind or they can you know
punch him in the gut like I said and he
wouldn't be able to absorb those attacks
anyway guys to round up this video I
have two honorable mentions so the first
one is fat absorption we've seen fat gum
a few times in this series and on one
occasion he absorbed a full explosion
and then gave a controlled release to
avoid hurting anyone in the surrounding
area and the next honorable mention is
one for all we see all might use this
quirk to say 50,000 people from the
tokyo sky egg in addition to defeating
all those bomber villains with a single
punch and the fact that he saved cuicci
and Katherine celebrity on top of that I
didn't want to include this on the main
list because I knew I'd have to put in a
number one or at least you know close
and it just didn't feel right okay it
did not feel right but there you have it
those were the best quotes in my haircut
a mere vigilantes let me know if there's
any you think I missed out or if you
would rank anyone differently thanks for
watching and peace out